now I'd like to introduce today's
featured presenter professor Robert
Sutton Bob Sutton is a professor of
management science and engineering at
Stanford University he co-founded the
Stanford Technology Ventures program and
the Hasso Plattner Institute of design
also known as the d.school he's a fellow
at IDEO senior scientist at gallop and
an adviser to McKinsey and company bob
studies organizational change leadership
innovation and workplace dynamics he's
published over 150 articles and chapters
and written seven books
Bob's latest book is the
Survival Guide how to deal with people
who treat you like dirt his website is
Bob Sutton net and his twitter handle is
that is at work underscore matters now
I'm going to turn it over to Bob all
right thanks sherry great to be here and
I would like to welcome everybody who's
joining us this is going to be kind of
my first major presentation of the ideas
in my book so I'm really excited about
this and so let's jump into it and what
I'm gonna do is I'll talk for 25 30
minutes or so and and then we'll open it
up for your questions and so just keep
those questions coming and we'll answer
as many as we possibly can I love
questions especially difficult ones so
yes ask me the hard ones all right so so
let me give you a little context about
both the story and retelling today and
and the book that I'm going to be
talking about so about ten years ago I
accidentally got involved in writing a
book about workplace jerks a book called
called the no rule and there
were a couple strange things about that
one I never really considered myself an
expert on workplace jerks but one thing
led to another and things kind of
reached a point where I would go to
professional events to talk about
leadership or innovation or something
and people for example McKinsey
Consulting they would introduce me
is this is Bob Sutton he's done all this
stuff but really he'll always be the
guy so I got this kind of weird
situation and I kind of resisted writing
kind of a sequel to the book the reason
that there was pressure for a sequel
besides the fact that the first book
sold well so they always want a sequel
is that the first book really focused on
organizational cultures how to build an
organizational culture that was a
relatively civilized workplace and but
the response to it was just about
everybody I ever met at a cocktail party
my barber professional event journalist
and I talked about the journalist and I
got 8,000 emails that all essentially
asked the same question which was help
I'm dealing with an or a bunch
of them what do I do and the range of
these things was unbelievable for
example a Costco worker who had who had
jerky had a boss who was a jerk another
example of somebody who who was a jerk
was was a local CEO who described bored
holes and douche boards who were driving
him crazy
I had a Baptist minister write me about
mean parishioners and what to do about
it and and then a lot of questions about
clients and they kind of went over and
over again and and so what I do I worked
on other stuff such as leadership and
scaling and innovation stuff like that I
kind of keep a running folder of all
these different emails and I said well
maybe I'll get to him someday and just
to give you one more sort of example so
here's a cartoon so one of the fun
things we did for this book is we had
this cartoonist David Wilson who's
actually a political cartoonist for a
newspaper in Florida and so he do some
cartoons based on the new book the
Survival Guide and had this and
I have this guy write me an email really
long email about how he spent seven
years working for what he what he called
an $8 dollar hole factor at factory an
factory where there was just me
everywhere there was a mean owner he
described oh he had he turned mean and
he had trouble sleeping he had physical
health problems he had trouble with his
relationship with the significant people
in his life and and one of the favorite
scenes and this is one of those weird
things that jerky people do is they're
weird about food so the picture there is
what would happen is that the owner
would walk up to him and stick his hand
into his bags of potato chips and just
eat them without permission so that's it
so these sort of questions and stories
that I would hear were kind of the focus
of the book and what we're going to talk
about in in following 20 minutes or so
are some of the lessons that I've
learned in this adventure over the last
decade to try to understand how to
address really this one question because
this book just addresses one question in
a lot of ways I'm dealing with a jerk or
a bunch of them expecially in the
workplace what do I do about them
alright so let me start out and talk a
little bit in addition to this big pile
of emails that I was getting that that I
was that I was getting that over the
years the academic literature on all
things absolutely exploded over
the years so and if you do a search
search engines that are especially for
scholarly research things like abusive
supervision abusive customers bullying
workplace victimization you can see the
list there it's just astounding how much
research there is that academics have
compiled over the years and although and
we might want to talk about this in the
QA there actually might be situations
where you individually might be able to
get ahead at least for a little while by
treating other people like dirt so
there's some controversy there about
what are the conditions under which if
you will finish first there's
not a lot but the thing that comes
through these literally thousands of
studies
is that if you are if you will if you
will inspiring range if you're around
people who treat others with disrespect
in a demeaning fashion who are rude who
do backstabbing we can talk about some
of the main if you will kinds of dirty
work that jerks do it's all bad news
thousands of studies so if you look on
the left-hand side of the side the slide
the evidence for well-being that if you
are confronting especially over a long
period of time but even short little
snippets someone who leaves you feeling
bad about yourself like dirt anxiety
depression poor relationships with other
people in your family there's great
longitudinal studies even done in the UK
that showed that people who have nasty
bosses have heart problems in higher
mortality rates so that's the one side
that for you it's bad and then in terms
of stuff that will might be bad for your
career and bad for your employer less
productivity more errors poor customer
service so what ends up happening is if
your boss and co-workers treat you like
dirt you in turn that's if you will
rolls downhill we'll we'll treat clients
bad as well there's some great research
in large chains of fast-food restaurants
that when the manager who runs the
restaurant treats the employees badly
they waste and steal more food and
turnover absenteeism so so regardless of
maybe these conditions which we could
talk about when maybe being a jerk helps
you get ahead it's a pretty rare set of
situations and probably overestimated
it's bad for your organization and bad
for your health to be around people like
this so so that's a very clear message
from from the academic research one
other thing and here's another one of
these Dave Wilson cartoons that's also
important another way in which it's bad
for you is that if you are around people
who treat you with disrespect and jerks
it's a contagious disease it's
contagious disease in two ways
that come out of the academic literature
one is if you are around nasty people
you
are likely to catch it just like a
common cold they can produce us in the
laboratory they bring in subject they
treat him or her like dirt and they
bring in another subject in that turn
person in turn turns into a dirt it
turns into a nasty person and there's
also evidence to breed like rabbits
quotes that there's this thing that the
Harvard professor famous Harvard
professor named Rosa Beth Kanter she
described it as homo social reproduction
that organizations tend to people pick
people who are just like them so
literally jerks are more likely to hire
jerks so if you hire one or two and
careful they will breed like rabbits all
right so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna start moving to the survival part
of the show if you will but before I do
let me give you a little mental
provisioning and something that really
I've learned especially over the last
decade but from the academic research
from talking to people are jerks and
honestly when I've been a jerk myself to
weeman beings have so many self-serving
biases we're so bad at seeing our
weaknesses that including for things
like disrespect or that that
we're not very good at recognizing when
we've treated others with disrespect or
are consistently disrespectful or nasty
but on top of that we're pretty quick to
blame other forces outside of ourselves
so so if you want a kind of if you will
mental provisioning a mantra as you're
dealing with managing situations where
you feel as if you're being demeaned the
energized oppressed whatever I would
swear to suggest be slow to label others
as but be quick to label
yourself as one because you're by doing
so you're countervailing a whole bunch
of other psychological forces
well-documented psychological forces
that push you the other direction okay
so here's my four main sets of survival
methods these are chapters in the
Survival Guide so let's sort of
jump in and and start talking about them
the first
the best thing you can do is make a
clean getaway if you are in a situation
it could be a customer we'll talk about
customers in a little bit it could be a
co-worker it could be a boss it could be
a Lord of the Flies situation where
everybody treats everybody else like
dirt doing the best you can to get out
as quickly as you can is really smart
then I've got Johnny paycheck you may
have heard the famous Johnny paycheck
song take this job and shove it but my
reaction is yes do this but don't be
stupid about it in such a way that it
particularly ruins your career in your
reputation and just one little example I
suspect many of you have heard of is
back in 2010 there was a guy named
Steven Slater who was briefly an
American folk hero so what happened was
he's a flight attendant on JetBlue
airlines and he has two legs with a
couple of really really obnoxious female
passengers who are just berating him so
he lands the second time I believe was
in Pittsburgh and one of the folks who
had been berating him one of the
customers she stands up early with a
plane still taxiing opens the overhead
blockage and he runs up to stop her and
he gets hit on the head really hard so
he's pissed and he's been abused by
these people for a few hours so what he
does is famously gets on the microphone
passes them all out called tells them
they're all jerks says he quits and
that's where you see the slide grabs two
beers intact
activates the slide and runs away from
the airplane and so if you want a made
for media take this job and shove it
story this is perfect but let's go back
to the don't be stupid about it he
expressed regret later he got fired
he got fine he was on probation for a
year so it's one of those things that
might feel good in the moment and if
somebody who has sometimes has limited
emotional self-control
I know it's often good to have a plan
and that's one of my general models and
mantras in the book too
back to it's good to have a plan is that
I wish I could just give you a formula
or a decision tree that
if you have a jerk if you do these three
things everything's going to be great
but unfortunately we all are in such
different situations that I can't give
you a one-size-fits-all solution so each
one of us if you will have to craft our
own Survival Plan based on what
we know and in consultation with people
who we know and trust all right so one
other thing so I'm talking about making
a clean getaway even better than that is
when you're going through the interview
process the job search process any sorts
of information you can get that you are
about to get involved with somebody who
is going to treat you like dirt and be
disrespectful it's really important to
look for of course you can you can do
things like read Glassdoor online which
isn't that reliable because you don't
know what part of the organization
you're going to end up in socially
positive gossips really important if you
have friends or people you can get to
friends of friends of friends who work
in the work group you're going to go to
that's probably the best information and
if you can have some early meetings you
might look for red flags and just the
example I'm going to talk about so the
reason I've got a hippo there is if you
think about hippos nipples have a big
mouth and they have little ears so so
that's one way in which hippos are
difficult to work with also there's
another meaning of hippos some of you
probably heard of which is the highest
paid person in the room and those two
things usually go together so anyhow
this is eight or ten years ago and one
of my co-authors who I've actually done
a lot with it Stanford masane first
Center for professional development and
and we've written books together and
stuff huggy Rao so Patti and I had this
potential consulting client and we flew
to Boston for an all-day meeting and
we're trying to figure out how much to
work with this guy and his team so when
this this conference room for ten hours
nine hours one of those horrible all-day
meetings and the guy who was head of the
group he talked and he talked and he
talked and he talked and he only made
statements he never asked us any
questions he talked and he talked and
it's about two o'clock and so
finally he sits that down next to me and
he was actually silent in somebody else
talked and he leans over and he looks at
me and he said it's the quote it looks
like I'm listening but I'm really just
reloading trying to figure out what I'm
gonna do next so after that meeting
huggy and I very quickly announced to
our client that we were too busy to work
with him and and I think that saved us a
lot of aggravation all right the next
set of approaches so if you're in a
situation where where you actually can't
avoid if you will working with for a
short or a long period of time with
people who are jerks
the way that I think about it is is that
Ness is sort of like kryptonite
all sorts of evidence that the closer
you are to this nasty stuff the more
frequent your exposure and the more
intense exposure the worse your physical
and mental health will be and also the
more likely you are to turn into a jerk
so this is my colleague Katie dis Ellis
it's actually her picture at CNN and she
on CNN and she visited Stanford a couple
of years ago and she studies all things
she studies air rage she studies
the relationship between prison guards
and prisoners she studies temper
tantrums by basketball coaches to see
the effects of it she so it was really
great having her next door to me and I
said to Katie some point working on the
book so Katie what's the most important
single bit of advice you have and I kind
of like her don't engage with crazy and
she means create as much distance from
crazy as you possibly can given the
reality of your life okay so let me give
you an example of something that I
learned from a former doctoral student I
know about how to limit the exposure in
this it to me this is a really important
powerful method when you can't make a
full xscape in this idea of sort of
slowing the rhythm to reduce the contact
and in this instant world we're in we
get emails and texts and stuff all hours
of the night people can send them
repeatedly phone calls meetings and so
on
and and what this doctoral student did
was she figured out as the quote there
says with
she had a batshit-crazy advisor he would
do things like holler at 3:00 in the
morning and yell at her and ranted her
writer repeated one email after another
after another often very critical and
often very hostile and the and she's
kind of stuck with this dissertation
advisors trying to figure out what to do
and she starts realizing that for him
and there are certain sorts of
especially maka valiant who
your if you will your pain is their
pleasure when they see you that really
long explanatory email they see you
suffering they see you crying and they
see you squirming the pleasure centers
in their brain light up and this is the
kind of she was dealing with so
what she learned to do was to slow the
rhythm so if he called she wouldn't
answer it or she would answer every
fifth or sixth call if he said a nasty
email she'd wait for the next nasty
email the next email email and the first
year so she'd wait a couple days and by
the time she finished her PhD
she'd wait two or three weeks and just
send one sort of neutral email response
and wait another few weeks
same thing with meetings she would she
had the meeting stretched out first
weekly bi-weekly then monthly and this
idea of slowing the rhythm is one of the
things that you might be able to do
within the constraint of a real job
another thing and I didn't put it in the
stack but it's really important there's
really great research that if especially
for those of you who work in an open
office environment if you can get a
little bit away physically far away from
the jerks in your office it has a huge
positive effect in fact there's a great
long-term study that was just published
described in the Harvard Business Review
in places that shows that when people
sit within 25 feet of a toxic coworker
the odds they're gonna turn to a jerk go
way up and so are the odds they're gonna
be fired so trying to get that extra 10
or 15 feet will have a big effect
another thing that you can do to reduce
the exposure is to find a safety zone a
place you can hide where the
can't get you at least for a while and
the reason I
this crazy old David Wilson cartoon is
this goes back to that I was so long ago
I had a full head of hair this was like
in the 1980s this is a really long time
ago and my colleague Dan Dennison and I
in Michigan we were sending a group of
surgical nurses and we're standing there
in the operating room an operating
theater whatever and we're talking to
the head nurse and she describes this
doctor who had a history of sexual
harassment was a serious problem as she
describes it this female nurse runs down
the hall with this aforementioned doctor
grabbing her bun so she looks at us and
go see well a few minutes later her and
a number of the other female nurses went
into the went into the nurses lounge and
we tried to follow him in she put up her
hand
you can't go nearest a nursing room in
the nurses lounge this is our territory
for safety so finding a place to hide is
can be useful use a human shield this is
what a boss is for if you get a great
boss what a great boss does and there's
research on one of the functions of
management is to buffer employees from
disturbance and annoyance if you can
find a boss who serves as a human shield
that's another way to deal with the
so that's picking your boss is
really important and so this I love this
quote from a sports director who wrote
me some years ago I always university
sports director I always tell the people
who work for me the same thing my job is
to hold the umbrella so the from
above doesn't hit you your job is to
keep me from having to use it so that's
such a symbiotic relationship all right
one other thing that I kind of got
obsessed with is this notion that when
there's work groups especially when
they're sort of a jerky boss that some
friends there's early warning systems
where people formally and informally
create social connections to warn that
the nasty boss is coming or that the
boss is in a particularly bad mood and
I've got that's a lot of emails about
this and there's stories in the press
but but a great example of this there's
an old methanol Sandra Bullock movie
where she plays a really nasty
the publisher who is despised by
over coworkers she was run and yelled
people's and littles people and so they
had an early warning system and what
happened was so the movie was called the
proposal so what happened was that her
assistant figured out that she was gonna
be coming in Disney another another
building another room so that's what the
email that was sent the witches on her
broom this sort of warning that if you
will there's an incoming ass so
sometimes those things can help alright
I think that's enough avoidance
techniques now let me talk about ones
that are really powerful for reducing
the negative effect of somebody who
treats you like dirt on yourself without
really changing the behavior
your situation at all so this is dr.
Aaron Beck he's the modern founder of
something called cognitive behavioral
therapy which is the most widely used
evidence-based therapy actually in the
world and a lot of what happens in
cognitive behavioral therapy is rather
than just changing your situation you
reframe and essentially change your
perception so that things that are
driving you crazy and making you sick
and making you anxious you reframe them
so they're less upsetting even good
things so so let me give you a few
examples that are kind of loosely drawn
from cognitive behavioral therapy so one
thing that happens in cognitive
behavioral therapy is that you'll recode
the threat as less nasty threatening
upsetting and you did before so let me
give you a couple of examples of where
I've seen this in my work in my research
so one of the heroes of my book her name
is Becky Mar Giada that heast
magnificent human being one of the most
accomplished social activists I've ever
met in my life that he actually led a
campaign called the hundred thousand
homes campaign that found homes for more
than a hundred thousand homeless
Americans she's a woman who can get shot
get stuff done so Becky in the 1980s
went to West Point the US Military
Academy she was
one of the few women in the early days
at West Point and if you know anything
about West Point or in fact any military
academy there's a lot of hazing the
first year so Becky she's first year
plebe and the typical thing that would
happen I love the way she describes it
is that so it's nine o'clock in the
morning in an upperclassman upper-class
cadet walks up to her and it gets a
intramural nose and says repeat the
major headlines of the New York Times
today this morning this is standard
hazing so she said you go and you try to
repeat it and of course you get it wrong
wrong and they'd scream at you and tell
you what an idiot you were one inch from
your nose so she said the first couple
of weeks she'd get all upset but then
she came up with the strategy of just
seeing them as these sort of brilliant
people who were really really funny who
really won't hurting weren't hurting her
they were sort of like a performance she
was walking watching in the theater and
he can see its idea of sort of not
having an E that bad and that's one of
the things that helped her get through
and she became very successful she was
involved in Special Operations had a
very successful military career bill
collectors years ago in the 90s I did
some anthropological research on
telephone bill collectors the people who
call us when you're late on your Visa
and MasterCard and one thing that we
were talked we were taught when we get a
screamer some of you would threaten us
they'd yell at us a lot of the whole
culture was afterwards you debrief with
your fellow collectors and they'd all
say the same thing
oh that's nothing you should have seen
what happened to me standard sort of
solution okay that's one another one
what I kind of like is when some of
these nasty and abusive and art and all
this sort of stuff rather than this sort
of lesson lesson the degree to which it
hurts you is is rather than getting
angry at with him then feel sorry for
them and forgive them so some of the
expressions here is you say to yourself
if you've got a jerky bus she's like a
porcupine with a heart of gold maybe
there's some good in there he's I heard
this at Google years ago he's like a guy
with a bad user interface but a good
operating system and the the key thing
here about having
sympathy having forgiveness or somebody
who treats you badly if even if you
don't change your behavior there's all
sorts of evidence that when you can
forgive people and have some distance it
does less harm to you because you don't
ruminate it you're not obsessed with it
so in some ways one way to blunt the
effect of an who even wants to
hurt you is to forgive that person
anyway okay another one which is kind of
related this is the Michelle Obama when
they go low we go high philosophy is
this notion that when people treat you
like dirt that you rise above it and say
you're not going to stoop to that level
and and when we're in the course of
doing the research for the book I ran
into a guy named Jacob Jabbar Jacob
Jabbar is a CEO of a copy chain that's
mostly out here on the west coast called
spills coffee they're infiltrating other
places like Washington DC and the like
and they're really into this notion that
they make you this custom cup of coffee
and you have this relationship with your
barista take him cause of cups of love
and he said his perspective was our our
view is that if customers nasty to you
you throw the kindness back to them you
kill them with kindness so one of my
students I hired her and she went out
and did a bunch of interviews with fills
I'm coffee folks and sure enough can see
the quotes here their whole culture was
essentially to not to stoop to the level
of customers and to kill them with
kindness because acting like that is
beneath them so that's that's another
kind of interesting strategy then two
more to my favorite ones this one
probably is one of the strongest
evidence-based approaches if you're
dealing with somebody who's a jerk to
create some distance between you and
them do a little imaginary time travel
they call this temporal distancing
there's great laboratory based studies
that show whether it's something like
breaking up from a long-term
relationship having trouble with the
test that that people who think about it
in terms of how they're going to feel
about it a week from now a month from
now a year from now
rather than focusing on how upset they
are they tend to suffer much less upset
anxiety depression and so on and when it
comes to this is one of the
things that I would see over and over
again as a coping strategy and one of my
favorite ones I guess I'm doing a lot of
military academy ones is the guy wrote
me that when he attended the Air Force
Academy and he was being hazed because
we know this was part of the thing
you're being hazed he said he would look
past them and he'd imagine it was three
years from then and he was in his plane
flying and this was nothing to get
through to be able to have the privilege
of flying the plane and it worked for
him so a little imaginary time travel
can be very powerful
finally in a lot of what I'm talking
about there's ways to become more
emotionally detached and distance from
the person who is treating you like dirt
and they call these reframing sometimes
emotional detachment strategies they're
called all sorts of ways and you could
sort of see it in that Air Force plebe
trainee that I was just talking about
you would find a way to do emotional
distance but one of my favorite one
comes actually from a Stanford
administrator I know who is one of the
most serene people at dealing with well
I hate to admit it we're sitting here at
Stanford around the table with multiple
people but we do have a few
maybe fewer than other organizations but
we got him so anyhow so what this guy
does I almost use his name that would be
terrible
and I I studied these people he doesn't
as he says he imagines when he goes into
one of these meetings that he's a doctor
who specializes in studying different
breeds of ISM of observing their
behavior of categorizing them and what
he does is the nasty when somebody is
nasty instead of getting upset he says
to himself I'm so lucky to see such a
fascinating specimen of this rare
behavior close-up and and it actually
worked so this idea of finding some ways
to distance and this person it's amazing
how skilled he is at this so that's
that's when you might use that I should
use but I don't because I study
okay so what we're gonna do so get your
questions in we're gonna talk for about
five minutes about
back five or six minutes then I'll wrap
up and then I'm just dying to hear your
questions okay so if you were in a
situation where there are people who are
treating you like they're making the
decision about whether or not to fight
back or somehow another change their
behavior is something I encourage people
to do but with proper precautions and
some of the things you might want to
think about how much power do you have
relative to the person who you're it
were with if if you're the boss and have
the power to fire the it's your
company you have all the assets you can
probably fire them if it's a situation
where you're the boss after you their
senior powerful people after you there's
a powerful coalition in that case you
got to watch it and maybe you might get
more power by I'm causing or by forming
a posse of people but you really got to
be careful documentation all sorts of
evidence both for legal reasons and and
just for making the case that the better
document documentation you have the
better able you are to fight back
against that Gherkin just just to give
you an example of a recent case a former
Stanford undergrads I've actually met
years ago so women named gretchen
carlson some of you men you probably
know this story she worked for Fox News
she also the reason I know is she's
undergraduate as one of my students was
dating her and he and she became Miss
America so he did very well understand
for dating pool so anyway so so Gretchen
years later so she's working at Fox News
and Roger Ailes then the president of
Fox News was constantly propositioning
her in sexually harassing her what she
did was she got her iPhone out and she
recorded hidden hitting on her and and
making threats and so on so she had very
good documentation one thing I should
warn you if you are in the state of
California it is unlawful to record
people without their permission but
different you're in New York it's legal
and there's also options the harder you
fight back
my advice is the more the better if you
can afford to not have the job if you
got other jobs lined up that's great but
if it's going to cost you feeding your
family or
paying your mortgage be a little careful
okay so those are some warnings let's
talk a little bit about different with
different ways to fight back one is and
this is especially if you're dealing
somebody who is an unintentional kind of
I calls clueless rather than
strategic who wants to be good
but isn't quite getting it pulling that
person aside and saying you're hurting
my feelings or you're being obnoxious
please stop so one of my favorite
examples this was actually one of our
SCPD Stanford executive programs I was
talking some about jerks and this woman
comes up to me issues an executive vice
president and she says to me so I had
this great incident with my CEO last
week where we'd have meetings would be
two of us it was two women four men all
executive vice presidents and what would
happen was and there's lots of research
on gender and interruptions the male CEO
was constantly interrupting the two
women never interrupting the other four
men so they carefully they needed
account they brought the male CEO the
evidence and said look what you're doing
you're being sexist he was horrified he
felt terrible about himself and he
changed his behavior in fact he would
ask them to count and keep doing it now
this is sort of the best possible
situation because this is if you will a
clueless rather than a strategic
but a lot of times you it's good to
assume good intentions okay there are
other types of jerks other types of
who well they're doing it on
purpose and they want you to suffer
I mentioned the mock abelian
those kind of people are in particular
research on Machiavellian is if you're
nice to someone who's Macha valiant they
take it as a sign that you're a doormat
and they can keep pushing and and if you
got somebody like that maybe biting back
aggressively might be worthwhile and so
one of my favorite stories when another
email I got is this woman wrote me about
this major she worked with he
was a retired US Army Major who was
constantly berating her and getting
nastier and nastier nastier until as it
says she gave him a hard stare very
loudly and told them that such behavior
was absolutely unacceptable and he
backed off but a lot of it depends is
you know one of my mom
I guess is no your the different
require different sorts of
approaches here's another one speaking
of knowing your so this is a CEO
I met and I can't name the company but
he's actually very proud of this
incident and and a very successful CEO
in the 1980s he built he was CEO of a
company that had a great IPO very
successful all of you would have heard
of it but he was really kind of a rough
guy who was really tough on his top
management team and he had he told this
whole story he approved it we've talked
to other members of the team this is
fact check and what what happened was he
had a pension for vegetable insult so
here's two of his favorite favorite
written himself you are dumber than a
head of lettuce and the average zucchini
could figure that out okay so this guy
unless his name keeps insulting his team
so what'd they do to get back at him and
send the message
we'll be a little more civilized so
that's the boardroom of the
aforementioned company in the 80s he
showed up and everybody's place was a
lettuce head with hats and sunglasses
that's his lettuce fed at the front of
the table they made up t-shirts they all
laughed about it but it delivered the
message to this obnoxious CEO that you
turn it down a little bit and he said to
me before I would start doing another
vegetable insult I would laugh and think
about the t-shirt I was wearing or what
happened that day and it got me to calm
down
I like that story all right so one thing
also in many of the organizations you're
in you can use the system to defeat
jerks the example here because I was
like to make sure that I haven't I'm
equal opportunity of both female and
male as there's this guy or
this woman sorry Captain Holly Graf she
was given a command of a very large Navy
Cruiser and was one of the fastest
rising young officers in the US Navy but
words kept coming out that she was
extremely abusive yelling at the little
ring hollering and swearing at and also
exploiting for exactly I think that she
had some of the officers mowing her lawn
and doing stuff like that and cleaning
her house to some stuff like that anyhow
so what happened was that it was
reported there was an investor
and she wasn't fired but she was removed
from her command and given less
responsibility so that's a case where it
actually works I also do tend before we
move to wrap up is I wish I could tell
you that HR or even the law was your
friend but you've got to be very careful
because in many organizations HR is not
your friend and if you go to the system
they're going to protect a more powerful
person rather than you so knowing if you
will knowing the system you're in and
how much power the person has is really
important
and in particular this is something else
I should emphasize this guy named Gary
Namie who runs the workplace bullying
Institute and he points out that it's
probably that it's legal in all 50 US
states to be an equal-opportunity
so if you're being discriminated
against or abused because you're you're
a woman you're a minority some other
protected class are disabled you've got
a better case but even then if you go
through a legal process it's always
important to remember if you start
getting to post and everything very
often they will drag your name through
the mud and even if you win in the
process you may suffer quite a bit so
I'm a big believer and yes sometimes you
can use the system but don't trust it
completely because it can turn pretty
ugly and turn on you okay let's move to
wrap up my general view of wrap up is
that if you are dealing with workplace
jerks your job is to be part of the
solution not part of the problem and
that's something we've all got to take
responsibility for and this chart might
be a little hard to read there was just
in a Wall Street Journal article that I
wrote but the key thing that comes out
of this let me give you the headline
when you look at national surveys of
bullying there's numbers that don't add
up about 50% of Americans report that
they have been victimized or observed
repeated bullying over time less than 1%
about 1/2 of 1% are willing to admit
that they have been the bully so and
this is back to this notion that that we
have very bad self awareness and us
human beings are very bad at admitting
we do things wrong and there's
evidence because of our lack of
self-awareness the worst way to figure
out if somebody is a bully or an
is to ask them because we have all have
such bad self-awareness the best way if
you are one or if you want to find out
if somebody else is one if to ask the
people around them and in particular if
you want to contain your inner jerk one
of the best things you can do is to have
close relationships family members
mentors co-workers who've known you
forever the people who will pull you
aside and tell you you are blowing it
you are not being so nice and one of my
favorite examples of great historical
couple Clementine and Winston Churchill
they were married for years and what
part of clementines job was to tell
Winston the truth and keep him under
control and there's this great letter
that one of my doctoral students Yocum
why'm sent me so it's 1940 it's the
darkest hours of World War two
England's being bombed this was around
the period of Dunkirk if you saw that
film and so Clementine writes this
letter to Winston Churchill which
basically says you're acting like a jerk
Winston so I love this one of the men in
your entourage a devoted friend has been
to me and told me that there is a danger
of your being generally disliked by your
colleagues and subordinates because of
your rough sarcastic and overbearing
manner
my darling Winston I love the darling I
must confess that I haven't noticed a
deterioration in your manner and you are
not so kind as you used to be and then
by the way she went on with this whole
mini theory later on that if you do this
people will be afraid to challenge you
with the truth so I love that letter
okay two more one more quick thing and
we're there so if I would have sort of a
mantra it's this notion that it's on you
when it comes to dealing with
problems and you're not alone
so what you're doing is you're kind in a
world where you have to work with others
to solve your problems and to avoid
imposing it on them and so the reason I
have the picture of the two porcupines
there's a little story that ends the
book that EO Wilson wrote about it was
it was came to him from a friend of his
and what it described was there was a
cool
night and there was a bunch of
porcupines and they were all cold and
when they all sort of slid close
together and got too close they poked
each other and it hurt that didn't work
so then they'd flip so far apart that
they were cold and what they did was
they spent the night getting just
exactly the right distance where they
could have warmth without hurting each
other and what they from then on called
that behavior was civility and good
manners and I kind of like that because
we go back to the survival stuff
my perspective is that we all needed
each other we need to take
responsibility and we're not alone and
we're sort of like those porcupines were
kind of shoveling back and forth and
every now and then we have to understand
we poke each other and every now and
then we got to understand we got to get
a little closer to each other to help
one another okay so that's the end of my
prepared remarks I'm looking forward to
your comments and questions I'm excited
to hear them and now let's get to the
questions
run okay let's start out we got some
really good ones coming in okay first
one what happens when the is
your boss
okay well that's oh so that's a hard
question but if you look at research on
who drive us crazy there's
enormous this there's an enormous amount
of evidence that bosses are the most
troublesome in fact the next
person up the hierarchy for all of us is
the person makes our lives wonderful or
terrible or both so a lot of
bosses out there 80% 75% of people
identified as and workplace
studies are abusive supervisors really
high number so there's lots of different
strategies that I've talked about in
terms of how much power you have you
have a posse do you document you just
need to take it so so this is why you've
got to formulate your own plan but let
me just tell you about the evidence
about the best way to fight an
boss documentation and form a posse all
sorts of evidence good both
anti-bullying studies is the more people
are on your side and the more
documentation you have that we get
social support and if you just go and
complain about your boss well
I don't know if you're resting Carlson
you got the recording that might be
enough and the big-time lawyer but for
most of us that's not going to work and
one of my favorite examples of this was
so this is a female somebody wrote me
years ago as an animal control officer
and they had a member of fellow animal
control officer constantly abusing them
swearing at them making racist comments
they go to the boss they complain
nothing would happen so what they did
was they formed they put together what
they called the diaries each one
of them for a two-week period just
recorded with dates all the different
incidents and all the horrible things
this person did as a group that five or
six of them went to the boss and then
that person was gone within a week and
that doesn't usually happen but there
you've got this idea of documentation
and a posse and a lot of it does depend
in the organization or some organization
where you can go to your boss's boss but
you damn well better know the political
environment that's a dangerous thing to
do in some organizations advice boss
yeah here's a good question many of our
participants work in distributed global
teams can you give suggestions for
managing jerks when you're not face to
face yes and in fact Pam Hines who is
one of our fellow faculty member she's
got an eye any one of our new executive
program she's one of the world's expert
on this so everything I know about this
I've learned from Pam Hines so look at
Pam Hines stuff
but here's what here so here's what the
research on distributed teams and in
fact even if you're in the same big room
and you're working on slack all day and
you're not talking to people it's just
as bad as if people are in other
countries by the way so to the extent
that you don't have I contact people and
you don't understand the context they're
in you are more likely to have problems
so the best thing you can do and
campaigns there's all sorts of evidence
if you're in a distributed team
expecially at the beginning of the
project if you can meet them even once
face to face before the project begins
that really helps them the other kind of
stuff that Pam talks about when you do
stuff that's distributed is it seems
like it's wasting time but it's not so I
don't know if you're in Germany or on a
phone call with somebody from India and
and and then maybe there's somebody in
Chicago or something like that
take two or three minutes oh there's
evidence to support this ask them where
they're sitting ask them what the
weather is like ask him what their
commute was like take a few minutes so
to humanize and to be able to get some
empathy for them but working in
distributed teams is really really tough
but it's something that we all need to
do and to go back to the slack example
or so many of us who work at home now
that almost all of us even when we in
theory are work in the same office or
office often essentially working on
distributed teams and the big morning
from the research is whenever you don't
have I contact and this includes the
telephone so what I'm doing to you right
now whenever you don't have eye contact
with the people you're working with
that's when people start getting nastier
and start having empathy problems that's
good so here's a good question that
actually I'm curious about as well from
reading your book why are you so
obsessed with positive enablers oxytocin
oh thank you thank you so toxic and it
was so I've got this whole thing about I
don't want you to be part of the
solution I mean part of the problem I
want you to be part of the solution and
and for all of us this notion that it's
on you and you're not alone it's on us
you're not alone but what happens in
organizational settings is there a lot
of people who are out there out there in
companies and the private sector of
politics and so on who aren't
but they clear the way for them and they
make it possible and so my last book the
no rule actually had a chapter
on the virtues of and I had a
set of guidelines if you want to be an
effective make sure you've got
somebody to clean up after you sort of
like after the parade comes to town the
people who sort of like clean up the
poop in the in the paper and everything
and it's old old research by Peter frost
University of British Columbia he
identified these people toxic enablers
toxic handlers who after the boss would
scream at people after the boss would be
abusive what the toxic handler would do
would go from office to office and tell
the people who in this case he abused
really he's not that bad a guy
he's not that bad he'll cool down later
and then the other part of the
enable that they do is when the
says what's that bad the toxic enabler
since there's a lot of ass-kissing
involved in this sense no no you weren't
really that bad and I talked to them
they're not really that upset so what
you're doing is you may not be a jerk
yourself but you may be enabling
somebody who is doing all sorts of
destruction and it's an interesting sort
of weird role and as I said
unfortunately the other Simon if you
want to be a successful jerk hire
yourself a confident top classic enabler
so I hate to bring that up but it's true
so how do we determine if you're dealing
with a natural or one who's just
been created by negative workplace
dynamic this question this is this
question is sort of sort of made
or born there is some evidence that
people who were bullies in high schools
go on to become bullies in the workplace
and they spend more time in prison and
all sorts of stuff but I'm actually I'm
glad you asked that question because one
thing I don't think I've emphasized
enough in this talk is that there's all
sorts of situations that turn almost all
of us into temporary and if you
look at modern life if you're in a
situation where you're rushed if it's
crowded oh it's hot if you're around
other people who are jerky it's Oh an
income disparity so we're in this income
and status disparity and to me the
perfect analogy is standing on a modern
airplane with first-class and and in all
the different statuses of the United
Airlines which unfortunately I might
have to fly a lot they have everything
from business class first class to the
absolutely you I think you can't even
put luggage in the overhead compartment
for the cheapest seats and and so what
they do is they create these status
dynamics and sort of a microcosm of
modern life so to me there's two parts
one is you may have some deep-seated
personality characteristics like
narcissism that makes you very thin skin
and very nasty but you just might be in
situations where there's just if anybody
would be a jerk and there's some great
experiments done with seminary students
so this is like these
people are training too you know to be
in the clergy and they put them in a
situation where they're in a rush and
there's somebody lying on the street who
seems to be dying with an arrest they
don't stop and help them because they're
in a rush so being in a hurry is one of
it was one of the most reliable way to
turn into a jerk but yeah you might have
personality problems but beware of
situations that can turn almost anybody
into a Dirk thank you so much Bob I have
to say we have a lot of questions we
weren't able to get to you can actually
see the value of getting time with four
experts like Bob here and we just want
to thank you so much for joining us
today
we hope you enjoy the hour and that
you're better equipped now to handle any
jerks in your workplace and we encourage
you again check out all of our offerings
at SCPD stanford.edu and again you'll
receive a recording of this webinar to
share with your friends and colleagues
and we wish you a great rest of the day
you